hey guys we're at the end of 2020 can
you believe that
it's been one crazy unpredictable year
it's not been easy for most of us but as
we looked back at this year
what have some of your highlights been
let me know
in the comments below it's another new
year that also means
time to list down your new year's
resolution how many of you have set
fitness resolutions in the past have you
achieved it
or have you just forgotten about it
according to a study
sixty percent of people give up on their
resolution by february
by march a whopping eighty percent have
totally let it go i don't want you to be
one of the statistics
i want you to be part of that 20 who
succeed
and i know you can do it i'm going to
share with you
seven ways to succeed in your fitness
resolution
before you can embark on a successful
fitness journey you need to find
your why the inner motivation within you
take a moment to assess why do you so
desperately want to lose the weight
if your answer is because i'm overweight
that's not good enough
you need to dig deeper for instance it
might be for your wedding that is coming
up
or a health issue or perhaps your weight
might be preventing you from doing
certain things such as
spending more time playing with your
kids be honest and ask yourself
what is your why that will give you the
strength to carry you
through your fitness journey if your
reason for losing weight and looking fit
is merely aesthetic or to look like a
certain celebrity
or influencer i would suggest that you
re-evaluate your motivation
because this could lead to an unhealthy
obsession
both physically and emotionally it's
important to
love and accept yourself before you can
make any changes
we're all different perfect in our own
ways
and we should embrace that once you have
found your inner motivation
write it down because this will be your
key
to success
what does toning up or losing weight
actually mean to you
how would you measure it what would you
do how long will it take you to get
there
in order to succeed you need to set
smart goals
your goals need to be specific
measurable
attainable realistic and time-bound
but how many of us actually apply it so
grab a pen and paper and write down your
smart
goal it has been proven that people who
write down their goals
are more likely to achieve them by over
70 percent
you can either write it down in your
journal or if you're mostly on your
mobile
you can also type it into your phone and
make it your wallpaper
don't stress out about it there is no
right or wrong and sometimes
you wouldn't know what you want until
you start
writing things down specific instead of
just saying i want to lose weight and
tone up
dive deeper my goal is to lose 25 kilos
this year measurable that's a great
start now
let's measure and calculate how long it
will take you to achieve
your goal if you were to lose 25 kilos
in 12 months
that's an average of 2 kilos a month and
half a kilo a week
by adding quantity to your goals and
breaking it down to smaller goals
this will allow you to track and ensure
success rather than focusing on a big
number 25 kilos which can be
overwhelming and scary
you're focusing on half a kilo a week
which is more manageable and attainable
is it attainable yes the safe and
recommended weight loss
is between half to one kilo per week
the heavier you are the quicker you will
lose the weight
especially in the early stages because
you have more fat to burn
the lighter you are the longer it will
take because your body has
less fat to burn set a realistic goal so
that you know you can work towards it
and you're setting yourself up for
success i've received
lots of comments asking how can i lose
10 kilos in a couple of weeks or
how can i get a flat belly in two weeks
don't expect that to happen
you didn't put on all the weight over a
few weeks
hence it will take time to lose the
weight
be realistic with yourself if you're
ready to invest your time and effort and
stop looking for shortcuts
then do this with me time-bound every
goal needs to be
time-bound otherwise there is no urgency
to want to achieve it
in this case the time you have set for
yourself is 12 months
setting a smart goal is only one small
part of the puzzle
it means nothing if you don't have an
action plan how are you going to achieve
your goal
what steps do you need to take what do
you have to sacrifice
i like to call this the action and give
list
in order to get what you want you must
be willing to make changes
compromise get out of your comfort zone
do things you have never done before
and even make sacrifices what i want you
to do is to create
two columns the first column is action
what do i have to do in order to achieve
my goal
the second column is give what do i have
to give up so the action column can be
i'll hit the gym three times weekly i'll
cook
two healthy meals a day i'll hit 10 000
steps
daily i'll get at least seven to eight
hours of sleep
daily the gift column can be i'll eat
takeaways only twice a week i have to
wake up an hour earlier
to get my workout done i'll cut down on
alcohol and only go out for a drink once
a week
i will spend the weekend to prep my
meals for the week
it doesn't have to be a long list but
rather a short list that you can focus
on and turn them into positive habits
once you have written down the action
and gift list weigh out the balance of
each column
make sure it's realistic to your
schedule and lifestyle
and consciously tell yourself that
you're ready to commit
to these lifestyle changes
[Music]
if you're someone who hasn't been
physically active and has been eating
fast food and takeaways for many years
start small and slowly build up the
momentum no
i'm not expecting you to hit the gym
every single day or cook
every single meal if you try to change
too much
too quickly you're setting yourself up
for failure
take it step by step and develop a solid
foundation of fitness
and then build upon that foundation as
your fitness improves
if you have no idea where to start or
how to structure your own workout
program
then do check out my own fitness app
called feel i've created few with the
focus on three main pillars of wellness
which is exercise food and mindset
we offer new monthly guided workout
programs with a combination of strength
training and cardio
each workout is only 30 minutes long and
you get to do it at home plus
all the workouts are taught by
internationally certified trainers
so you know you're in safe hands we also
have
over 100 really simple recipes to get
you started
as well as short videos to help you
train your mindset
in order to succeed so do check it out
on fieldlife.com or
download on the app store and google
play we know fitness resolutions are
hard to keep
and to be honest motivation can quickly
disappear
hence by using fuel you will be able to
schedule your workout
build your momentum and keep you
accountable which
leads on to my next point
i truly believe that when you're able to
share your goals and progress with
like-minded people
it will give you a sense of
accountability they will also be able to
offer you support
and motivation when things get tough it
can either be a workout partner
a family member who cheers you on a
personal trainer or
even an online community where you can
share your journey with
such as on field app or even my youtube
channel
right here you are always welcome to
share your weight loss journey
ask questions and even support each
other that's what we are here for
but know this who you share your goals
with is extremely important
i would encourage you to just openly
share it with anyone and
everyone you know over sharing might not
be a positive thing
because these people may end up
sabotaging you
oh she's trying to lose weight oh come
on
one slice of cake will not make you fat
so
how much have you lost the harsh truth
is that
not everybody is going to be excited
about your goals
there will always be people who will try
to bring you down
and you don't need that energy in your
life this is
your life your body your goal
if they are not offering any support
instead they make you feel unworthy
and like a failure your best bet is to
stay away from them
you don't need to waste your time trying
to explain or share yourself
you don't owe them an explanation
neither should you feel guilty
if you choose to avoid them only share
with someone who truly cares and wants
the best for you
together you can keep each other updated
get tips
advice and encourage one another the
only way to know if you're on the right
path towards your goal
is to track your progress there are many
different ways
to track your progress that can be
keeping a workout journal
having a workout journal helps you
determine how much exercise you're
currently getting in
and allows you to see your progress
whether it's the number of steps you
take
the number of times you work out the
kilometers you jog
or the time spent in the gym it's also
an effective method
to track the exercises and amount of
weight you lifted in your previous
workouts
this way you'll know if you're getting
stronger remember that progress is not
just about
the number on the skill but it's also
about you
getting stronger physically and mentally
weigh yourself it's important to weigh
yourself to know if you're on track
with the amount you need to lose saying
that however
i don't want you to be obsessed over
weighing yourself
every single day and determine your
success solely based on the number on
the scale
only weigh yourself once a week and know
that your progress
is not solely determined by the number
on the scale
if you're wondering why the number on
the scale isn't moving
but you feel that your clothes fit
better and that you look
slimmer that's because you have
increased in muscle mass
and reduced in body fat this leads on to
the next point
check your body composition meaning the
percentage of
body fat versus muscle mass as you
strength train
you will build muscle and burn fat your
body fat percentage will go
down and your muscle mass will increase
but your weight remains
the same that's because one pound of
muscle is more
dense compared to one pound of fat so
even if your weight remains the same
you will look more firm and toned most
fitness and health clubs will have the
machine for you to check
your body composition next take a
picture
i love to take post workout selfies it's
not about being vain
but rather it's a great reminder to
myself that i've completed another
workout session
and that feels good when we see
ourselves every single day we don't
always notice
the changes but as you look back at all
the pictures
and compare photos from 6 to 12 weeks
apart
you will definitely see the differences
at the end of the day
when you review your progress you can
look at ways to improve
and also celebrate small successes along
the way
and the final step is to know that this
is not just another
new year's resolution it's a permanent
lifestyle change
it's not something you stop once you
have lost x amount of weight but rather
it's about setting you on a path to a
healthier and happier life
forever so you got to work towards
achieving what you want
every single day forget about going on
the fast lane
and because it's a journey there will be
lots of
ups and downs and i can tell you right
now it won't be a smooth journey and it
won't be easy
you'll have days when you feel extremely
motivated and out of the sudden
you might fall back into your old habit
of binge eating again
if you can foresee this you can better
prepare yourself when it's about to
happen
and overcome it with certain strategies
remember do not turn
relapses or temporary failures into
meltdowns
or excuses for giving up instead
acknowledge the mistakes look at ways on
how you can better manage it when it
happens
and recommit to the path i believe
that achieving our goals isn't about
willpower it's about developing the
right skills and strategies
and with the right execution it will
lead to success
let me know what's your fitness goal in
the comments below and how you plan on
achieving that
this is your space so i would encourage
you to leave your comments
regularly and keep me updated in your
progress do also check out my
description box as i've added a lot more
links
to guide you through your fitness
journey if you find this video to be
helpful
do share it on with someone who could
benefit from this hit
the like button subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more workout videos
recipes as well as fitness tips and
let's start
2021 strong